open text a chip les vidéos consultées
consiste un enfant s'est attrapé par un
aigle médecine un canular en fait si le
legs les l'enfant n'existe pas d'abord
le projet étudiant tout simplement con
qu'on ait mis sur internet
le but être créé un déo virale on a
réussi en font leur uniquement mis sur
youtube vers le lendemain matin tous les
médias dans la mire kings ont appelé et
on a enfin qu'il fait enlever par un
aigle royal par quatre étudiants de
montréal la vidéo de l'aigle et du bébé
a été vue 44 millions de fois depuis sa
mise en ligne
une réussite inattendue pour loïc et
trois autres étudiants du nahd l'école
des arts numériques de l'animation et du
design de montréal qui ont réalisé ce
travail de fin de session en décembre
ce comme un écrivain saisirait qui sort
son premier best seller il va pas
nécessairement devenir une expérience où
le rêve de sa vie mais sa volée prouve l
humaine qui est capable d'écrire un
livre comme nous ça nous a prouvé qu'on
était capable de faire des images de
synthèse de qualité tout le monde
connaissait ce vidéo là dans l'industrie
donc c'est ce qui nous a permis de
trouver
je vais rapidement un emploi ils
inquiets ses collègues ne sont pas les
seuls canadiens avoir trouvé du travail
en partie grâce à youtube
justin bieber s'est fait remarqué 13 ans
en mettant en ligne des vidéos
sa carrière est propulsé deux ans plus
tard avec ce vidéoclip vu plus d'un
milliard de fois
c'est la deuxième vidéo la plus
populaire de l'histoire de youtube
après cannes hamster
chaque minute 300 heures de vidéo sont
téléchargées au point qu'un homme stars
du monde j'espère que vous allez bien je
content de vous retrouver aujourd'hui
pour faire une vidéo sur mes cheveux
parce qu'il me semble que ça fait
vraiment longtemps que j'ai pas fait une
vidéo dédiée à mes cheveux
j'aime tout cela en fait donc c'est moi
qui fais les éclairages la caméra le
montage à la base pour dire que je suis
maquilleuse c'est un projet qui dit ce
que j'ai fait j'ai ouvert ma chaîne sur
youtube donc on peut m'appeler timbers
beauté ou youtuber êtes un utilisateur
qui met en ligne du contenu vidéo sur
une base régulière
trois cent quarante mille personnes se
sont abonnées à la page youtube de
cynthia pour recevoir ses conseils
maquillage mode ou psycho
c'est l'une des francophones au pays qui
en a le plus maintenant à chaque fois
que je vais au centre-ville à montréal
cm un camion une fille qui vont vous
parler qui va me reconnaître donc ça
arrive souvent
c'est drôle parce que les gens autour
ont aucune idée les chiffres du trafic
aérien
une popularité numérique qui ne connaît
pas de frontière et qui l'a amené juste
en france et en suisse à la rencontre de
ces femmes
mais voir toutes les entrevues ch
capable et je me considère comme
chanceuse d'avoir pensé à youtube comme
deuxième job c'est pour aller partager
mes passions mes connaissances puis
aujourd'hui encore une fois je suis
assez chanceuse pour pouvoir en vivre
même encore aujourd'hui quand je dis aux
gens qu'on peut gagner sa vie avec eto'o
il regarde avec des gros yeux le film
demande comme un visa partout où vous
souhaitez sécuritaire aujourd'hui
sécuritaire demain c'est pourquoi la
formula one d'avignon plus d'un million
de comptes reçoivent de l'argent de
youtube
plus d'un millier engrangent des revenus
supérieurs à 100 mille dollars
les redevances se calcule en termes de
clics et de publicité choisi par le site
youtube se garde ensuite une commission
depuis 2007 le site affirme avoir versé
plus de deux milliards de dollars
américains à ses créateurs de contenu
bruni non je suis passionné par la
photographie de la vidéo toujours un peu
excentriques comme on dit
si vous demandez à mes amis ils vous
diront que j'ai toujours des idées un
peu fou sanguinaire dimanche après midi
j'ai acheter une baguette j'ai pris un
petit morceau je l' ai mis un peu du
dock type c3 du scotch aux gaufres au
nez creux est venu il a pris un moment
donné c'était comme s'ils voulaient
prendre une seule fille il a mangé le
pain puis il a laissé tomber le groupe
pro par la suite je l' ai mis sur
youtube com
immédiatement je voyais que ça il y
avait des centaines de milliers de
personnes qui le regardaient puis dans
une période d'une semaine où il s'était
rendu à 55.5 millions de visionnements
sherlyn de mal dans une vidéo j'aime le
partager avec le monde
si le but est de rendre une journée dès
qu'un peu plus amusant de mettre des
sourires sur les faces des hommes
je vous ai une vidéo que je voulais
explorer c'était quoi la vie d'une mii
de poule à montréal pour donner une
perspective différente puis comme je
savais c'était un risque une voiture l'a
écrasée plus finalement ça a brisé
je dois continuer à travailler comme
avocat toujours mais comme je disais à
ma femme ça j'ai regagné assez que ça
paie pour le go pro que j'ai perdu par
la suite
dans le cas des auteurs de la vidéo de
l'aigle les recettes provenant de
youtube ont été versés à leurs anciennes
écoles les 20000 dollars de revenus
publicitaires serviront à créer des
bourses pour favoriser la création et
peut-être la réalisation de nouvelles
vidéos qui feront sensation